parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je parle de bout de chemin je veux dire
départ de chez moi arriver au boulot
puis retour mais aussi possible tous les
jours merci à toi le covoiturage c'est
convivial économique écologique avec le
covoiturage saint quentin en yvelines
vous propose une nouvelle façon de vous
déplacer les inscriptions et les infos
sur
www.covoiturage.fr lotir et est-ce qu y
point fr
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' équilibre le magazine de
l'environnement un magazine spécial
fêtes de fin d'année nous verra où se
procurer son sapin de noël ken sortie
originale pour amuser les enfants et
comment les villes et clermont rue le
tout de façon écologique
pour le côté gastronomie nous voici à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet où
l'on peut se procurer des produits bio
et des produits festifs issus de
l'agriculture durable pour évoquer ces
produits nous sommes en votre compagnie
gérard et cher bonjour et merci de nous
accueillir vous êtes responsable des
boutiques gourmandes de la bergerie
nationale
alors quels sont ces produits qu'on peut
se procurer tout au long de l'année
alors les produits sont bien sûr tous
les vins des lycées viticoles ont fait
un tour de france des 20 ans passant par
la corse donc nous avons le en passant
par le champagne les cognacs des bières
nous avons aussi comme vous pouvez le
voir des conserves des conserves de
viande des conserves à base de poissons
des miel des confitures
dépotage des souffre
d
des légumes en conserve des ratatouilles
voilà nous avons du vin bio qui vient de
la scène les bornes donc là où nous
avons pu beaucoup mais nous sommes
livrés ont pas un frais tous les jeudis
matins et tous les samedis matin nous
avons aussi donc tous les produits
laitiers qui viennent de la ferme qui
est verbale grignon donc l'autre lycée
agricole qui fabrique donc les yaourts
avec le produit d
les produits laitiers du lot les
exploitations fromage blanc il ya août
aux fruits et après des charcuteries
les charcuteries aussi qui viennent
voilà de la roche sur foron nous avons
donc le lycée
de la roche sur foron nous avons un
petit producteur de lapin qui vient de
ré loire qui aussi exploitant et puis à
semblable son propre abattoir et qui
fait sa découpe nous avons en complément
de gamme des charcuteries qui viennent
d'un producteur du perche aussi qu'ils
ont leur porcherie qui ont leur abattoir
et qui transforment eux mêmes leurs
charcuteries nous avons quelques
volailles au citizen du perche des
volailles voilà qui sont un regroupement
d'agriculteurs qui ont
installez
disons des poulaillers tout comme ça ils
font un élevage de volailles ils ont
l'abattoir ils font eux mêmes les
livraisons tous ces produits sont issus
de l'agriculture durable pouvez vous
nous expliquer ce qu'est l'agriculture
durable alors l'une des missions de
l'enseignement agricole maintenant c'est
de montrer à leurs étudiants le
développement d'une agriculture donc dit
durable donc c'est bah ça va être limité
tout ce qui est en 30 ou les pesticides
fongicides ne traiter que si c'est
vraiment nécessaire et en condition en
quantité vraiment en minimale juste pour
empêcher que les ravageurs détruisent
les récoltes il ya l'aspect social aussi
évidemment on tient compte aussi du
personnel de ces étudiants du bien-être
on va dire du bien-être animal pour tout
ce qui est élevage donc c'est terminé
d'avoir des élevages un petit peu un peu
surchargé comme pouvait y avoir à une
époque les ports en cage les poulets
serré comme un peu des sardines donc
maintenant le bien-être animal et le
bien-être des agriculteurs et prévaut
dans l'enseignement agricole pour les
fêtes vous recevez aussi des glaces et
des bûches bio voilà comment voyez nous
avons des bûches glacées qui viennent du
perche sarthois
ce sont des les bûches des bûches de
noël fait donc au lait bio
en tout cas même pendant les fêtes pas
question de dépenser sans compter
désormais les communes ali les fêtes de
fin d'année à l'économie et au
développement durable grâce aux
éclairages led qui illumine nos rues
pour exemple voici les décorations de la
ville de plaisir
c'était très joli on vient de les
regarder pour la première fois c'est
surtout les enfants qui voulaient passer
par cette route pour les voir ça change
de l'ordinaire ils sont onze sympathique
un éclairage qui se veut également
écologique
la quasi totalité des communes du
département sont désormais passés à
l'éclairage led la vie de plaisirs a
pris le virage des 2009 qu'ils iraient
très étendue et on mettait sur chacun
des lèvres que ce soit ou gâtine à la
mare au sol là où à la boissière dans
les rues on mettait beaucoup de partout
d irlande des motifs et tous et il
s'avérait que ça revenait très cher
madère et tout ça donc on a dû j'étais
arrivé à 150000 euros le budget annuel
est désormais de 92 mille euros et la
facture d'électricité pour la ville est
passée de 3877 euros durant les fêtes de
2009 à 394 euros aujourd'hui grâce aux
leds autres bénéfices le led a une durée
de vie 10 fois supérieure aux éclairages
classiques fini les ampoules constamment
en panne qu'il faut régulièrement changé
et a permis de passer aux motifs en
trois dimensions d'avoir plus de
couleurs et de choix le changement et
l'innovation sont les bienvenus ils sont
là de bonheur et c'est bien ça met de la
gaieté et les enfants ils aiment bien ah
oui c'est très joli là j'ai vu ce matin
en allant boulot ils ont installé un
un petit ours et un petit anton pour
autant depuis trois ans seules les
entrées de la ville la mairie le marché
et les ronds points sont ornés de
décorations ici à plaisir les
illuminations dans chaque quartier c'est
du passé car les installations de ses
décors en location restent onéreuses et
malgré les fêtes et l'ambiance festive
qui s'y rattachent leur reste avant tout
à l'économie
pour décorer son salon de l'ultime sapin
est inutile d'aller bien loin nous voici
à saint lambert des bois près de saint
quentin en yvelines en votre compagnie
daniel barbier bonjour jour vous êtes
pépiniéristes
funérailles voilà vous ne recevez
aujourd'hui sur votre propriété
cultiver des sapins donc avec quel type
de sapins peut-on trouver ici
nous avons du pi ca ou épicéa
du norman abs norman diana et puis
stephen jones et abies nobilis et des
sapins bleus tu es aussi nobilis et paul
james les deux sont de leucate
l'épicéa perdre leurs aiguilles canton
les rentes à l'intérieur une fois coupée
par contre le nordmann nuit et ils se
les aiguilles se rétracter ce garde
corps et au niveau 2 du parfum d alors
sapin le l'épicière ont une odeur un peu
bonne odeur que le norman n'a pas du
tout d'odeur
donc il vaut mieux prendre enfin selon
ses goûts alors d'un côté on a des
avantages au côté inconvénients le
nordmann garde ses aiguilles enfin se
rétracte 4 ses aiguilles s'il est coupée
mais il n'a pas d'odeur et le pi ca lui
une fois qu'on leur honte il faut une
quinzaine de jours et lahi les aiguilles
tombent mais bon en principe si on leur
antre le 20 décembre
quinze jours après la fête est finie
donc c'est que le sapin on n'a plus qu'à
les mettre par la fenêtre combien de
temps faut-il pour faire pousser un
fatah ben il faut il faut pour que qu'il
soit vendable oui sapin qui ça peu près
1 mètre 50 il faut bien une dizaine
d'années donc c'est un au travail ici
c'est du travail c'est de la taille
c'est bon la plantation la taille un peu
de ton temps et puis et puis et puis le
la nature un peu le soleil un peu d'eau
enfin bon oui c'est ça est ce qu'il ya
des années à sapin tout à fait il ya
c'est un peu comme le vin il ya des
années pousse beaucoup parce que c'est
une année par amp l'été est humide donc
le sapin pouces est par contre si c'est
une année plutôt sèche bail
ils poussent moins pour nous c'est plus
intéressant puisqu'il faut pas qu'ils
poussent trop vite sur ça il s'étiole
donc c'est pas voilà donc folle taille
et enfin ya tout un système qu'on aille
à un beau sapin bien bien voilà alors
quels sont les laits concurrence
aujourd'hui avec le sapin véritable est
ce que le sapin synthétique voilà est
une réelle concurrence aujourd'hui oui
et non
cc je dire que les gens qui ont
l'habitude du sapin il met du un sapin
mais il est vrai qu'un sapins
synthétiques
surtout que maintenant ils en font de
très beaux je devrais pas dire ça mais
bon malheureusement et c'est vrai qu'on
leur met dans une boîte et on ressort
d'un et suivante mais c'est quand même
un coût beaucoup plus important si on
veut un beau sapin naturel puis après
quand même la magie du du enfin du satin
quoi cc c'est quand même plus agréable
de voir quelque chose de naturel qui
rentre dans la maison de particuliers
vient avec ses enfants choisir un sapin
et on le couple de valence et c'est du
bonheur parce que voir les enfants
courir dans les sapins c'est c'est
celui-là suis un an suis la fille bon
voilà on choisit on veut on mesure on
dit le prix donc apprend le couple on le
hall emballé on le faisait on met le
pied puis voilà ils partent avec donc ça
peut être ça y'a pas plus frère
merci de rien c'est vrai que vous
remercie une fois le sapin de noël
décoré comment occuper les enfants
pendant les vacances scolaires une
solution la patinoire écologique de
versailles regardez
rice et déraper chuté pour la plus
grande joie des petits mais aussi des
grands une patinoire en plein air a pris
place devant l'hôtel de ville de
versailles pour la quatrième année
consécutive une patinoire particulière
elle est écologique elle fonctionne sans
eau sans électricité et les plaques de
polyoléfines peuvent être réutilisés
plusieurs fois ces autos lubrifié donc
on n'a quand même pas encore tout à fait
la qualité de la vraie glace mais ça
commence à rapprocher et comme on nous
avons nous un futur sur place qui nous
permet d'affûter les patins relativement
tout le temps à la quand même une église
qui reste très correct par rapport à la
vraie glace quand même un petit temps
d'adaptation parce que j'ai vraiment pas
l'habitude de faire de la patinoire
synthétique
moins dur que la glace véritable en cas
de chute mais aussi son humidité où ils
risquent pas d'être mouillés et
d'attraper froid c'est excellent c'est
un peu différent du parthe patins
ordinaire c'est un peu faut un petit
temps d'adaptation
mais c'est marrant
et pour reprendre des forces gaufres
crêpes et boissons chaudes régale les
visiteurs c'est génial c'est super les
enfants s'amusent bien et on passe un
très bon moment on a l'impression d'être
en vacances avant l'heure
chaque année entre 5000 et 6000
patineurs viennent s'exercer sur la
patinoire éphémère qui restera ouverte
jusqu'au 6 janvier
ainsi s'achève ce numéro d'équilibré
spécial fêtes de fin d'année merci de
l'avoir suivi avant de nous quitter
quelques dates à noter dans vos agendas
la maison de l'environnement propose les
19 26 et 27 décembre un atelier conte
petits et grands la coopération qui a co
l'occasion de découvrir grâce à des jeux
interactifs
l'apprentissage de la citoyenneté et des
valeurs du faire ensemble pour réussir
et plus les fêtes de fin d'année sont
aussi l'occasion de plus de solidarité
envers les plus démunis les père noël
vert du secours populaire animeront les
rues des marchés des places mais aussi
des galeries marchandes les collectes de
jouets de cadeaux et de dons financiers
permettent aux plus défavorisés de
bénéficier d'un véritable noël mais
c'est tout au long de l'année que peut
s'exercer la solidarité nous on se
retrouve le 18 janvier pour une nouvelle
année encore plus écologique d'ici là
très bonne fête à toutes et à tous ciao